On behalf of the American people, including Muslim communities in all 50 States,...
...I want to extend best wishes to Muslims in America and around the world.
Ramadan Kareem.
Ramadan is the month in which Muslims believe...
...the Koran was revealed to the Prophet Muhammad,...
...beginning with a simple word, iqra.
It is therefore a time when Muslims reflect...
...upon the wisdom and guidance that comes with faith,...
...and the responsibility that human beings have to one another and to God.
Like many people of different faiths...
...who have seen Ramadan through our communities and families,...
...I know this to be a festive time, a time when families gather and meals are shared;...
...but I also know that Ramadan is a time of intense devotion and reflection,...
...a time when Muslims fast during the day and perform tarawih prayers at night,...
...reciting and listening to the entire Koran over the course of the month.
These rituals remind us of the principles that we hold in common,...
...and Islam's role in advancing justice, progress,...
...tolerance, and the dignity of all human beings.
For instance, fasting is a concept shared by many faiths,...
...including my own Christian faith,...
...as a way to bring people closer to God...
...and to those among us who cannot take their next meal for granted.
And the support that Muslims provide to others...
...recalls our responsibility to advance opportunity and prosperity for people everywhere.
...for all of us must remember that the world we want to build...
...and the changes that we want to make...
...must begin in our own hearts and our own communities.
This summer, people across America have served in their communities:...
...educating children, caring for the sick,...
...and extending a hand to those who have fallen on hard times.
Faith-based organizations, including many Islamic organizations,...
...have been at the forefront in participating in this summer of service.
And in these challenging times, this is a spirit of responsibility...
...that we must sustain in the months and years to come.
Beyond America's borders,...
...we're also committed to keeping our responsibility to build a world...
...that is more peaceful and secure.
That's why we're responsibly ending the war in Iraq.
That's why we are isolating violent extremists...
...while empowering the people in places like Afghanistan and Pakistan.
And that is why we strongly and actively support a two-state solution...
...that recognizes the rights of Israelis and Palestinians to live in peace and security.
That's also why America will always stand for the universal rights of all people...
...to speak their mind, practice their religion, contribute fully to their society,...
...and to have confidence in the rule of law.